how have things changed for you in these
past five years because you and i met
obviously your story is very famous and
people can watch the previous episodes
came from nothing hustled your way in
sleeping at the airport great book
you can go get arlen's book and uh hear
the whole history it's
super compelling but what's it like now
i'm curious because you've been on a
bunch of magazine covers you've invested
in over
i think over 100 companies now at this
180 180 wow what a pace
so so tell me what is it like in your
seven or six i don't know what year it
is for you 2016 was the first one i
think oh yeah
2015 is when it officially kicked off i
had worked on it for about four years
prior to that so i'm about a decade
into this experiment and about
five and a half years into it being a
real life boy
if you will um but today i mean do you
mean personally or do you mean the fun
so i i the way i was
thinking of it was how are you how do
you feel you were received early
in the middle and now yeah you as a
person
yeah i think yeah sure go ahead no i
it just was interesting to me sort of
the perception of a
black woman starting her own venture
fund and how that might have changed
over time because you were so early to
this
yeah i think uh at first people
really didn't know what to make of me
and what i was doing and for
in the first two or three years really
um thought you know a lot of people kind
of got
solidified in some ideas they had about
it not being a good idea
being too topsy-turvy it's too many
companies it's too early it's too small
all those things were said and i just
kind of like i say i put my hoodie up
and i walk towards the wind you know i
walk into it and i just don't listen to
all of that
and then i think in 2018 when i was on
the cover of fast company
a lot of people it was very polarizing a
lot of people said oh my goodness she's
getting that
so soon it's not she's not worth it
worthy of it etc
there's a lot of that backlash and then
there were a lot of people who
became really strong in their opinion of
wait a second there's something here
and we better keep a close eye on it
because it's very interesting and it's
inspiring
and so since then i kind of that really
was where a line in the sand was drawn
in my opinion
when i look back um that's when people
started calling me
rather than me chasing them down right
ah very nice